-You do something
on your website, as well.
You do one-second pizza reviews.
One bite.
-One bite.
-One-bite pizza reviews.
And I would like to do this
with you now.
Your rating system --
you do not do a 1 to 10.
-No, it is exactly a 1 to 10.
-Oh, you do do a 1 to 10.
-We go to one place every day.
I've been doing it
since I moved to New York,
a year and a half.
One pizza place
every single day.
-Gotcha.
-We give it a 1-to-10 score.
-What's your highest score?
Have you given a 10?
-It's like figure skating.
If you give a 10,
then you can't go above a 10,
so you're screwed.
-Gotcha.
-You can't do that.
So never a straight 10.
-What's the highest you've gone?
-9.4.
-Okay, great.
Let's do this.
-Now, in fairness,
it's a little cold.
So it may alter it a little bit.
-Okay, so, that's
like a level of difficulty that
the judges have to take into --
much like figure skating.
All right, here we go.
-Never bend those rules.
And you got to score.
-6.2.
[ Light laughter ]
-See, I -- with this, 7.2.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-That was Rose's
of Penn Station.
All right, congratulations,
Rose's of Penn Station.
[ Applause ]
All right.
-Have you had it in real life?
-I've never had
Rose's of Penn Station.
-Penn Station
is obviously trash,
but that pizza is pretty good.
-Yeah.
I feel like there's
enough good pizza
to not go to Penn Station
to get a 7.2.
-It's not that bad.
-Okay, here we go.
[ Light laughter ]
-One bite.
Everybody knows the rules.
-You're taking
so many other bites.
[ Laughter ]
By the way,
you do this on your videos.
Your videos, you say "one bite,"
and then you eat
the whole pizza.
-Smart guy, Seth.
-Smart guy. There you go.
-In the comedy business,
that's like a schtick.
-It's not a schtick.
it's an observation.
[ Light laughter ]
-Very good, very good.
-I give that a 6.5.
-See, for this one,
I've had this before, too.
This is like a 5.8,
but it's the temperature.
PizzArte, by the way,
they have art.
It's like a whole experience.
It's pretty good pizza.
-Wow.
-Cold hurts it a little bit.
That was very unfair of us
to do that.
But thank you so much
for being here.
Thank you for showing me
this incredible art form
of one-bite pizza.
Congratulations on your website.
Dave Portnoy, everybody!